do you have a little man in your life I
believe that every entrepreneur has a
little man in their life the little man
here who tries to hold us back who tells
us all the reasons why something's not
going to work out who doesn't believe in
us and if you want to accomplish your
goal if you want to go after that big
dream of yours you're going to have to
overcome the little man and believe in
yourself and on this channel I've shared
a lot of information in stores from my
own life from famous entrepreneurs lives
of how we've overcome the little man and
I was thinking about starting a new
series is where I need your help I'll
think it will start a new series where
we share together our stories of the
little man and i would like to invite
you if you're interested to share a
video story of how you have faced a
little man in your life and how you
overcame their criticism objections to
achieve success and to achieve the goal
that they said would never happen was
not possible and ideally like love to
have one a week of these coming out and
doing so i hope that it further
motivates you to keep going but also by
people learning from your story they
stay inspired and they stop listening to
little men in their life and they have
the courage to keep going because your
story helps serve as that inspiration on
top of getting some business promotion
free courtesy of my channel so if you
guys are interested if you have a little
main story that is inspirational that
you want to share with my audience to
help people overcome little men in their
lives then leave a comment below tell me
that you're interested and we'll take it
from there believe
you